So we're still still in the process of learning
about the police shooting that left Dontae
right dead in Brooklyn, Minnesota, that not
Brooklyn, New York, Brooklyn, Minnesota.
And yesterday, police had a press conference
about it, one of the strangest police press
conferences I've ever seen.
In the middle of it, the Brooklyn police chief,
Tim Gannon, just walked out.
He later returned.
There were questions as to why did he leave?
And the answers were very strange.
What we know is that police shot and killed
a black man on Sunday during a stop for a
traffic violation.
There have been protests.
There has been unrest.
I've looked at the video of the shooting,
which we will not be playing here, but you
can find it online.
We know that the officer announces that she
will be tasing, but then she pulls out her
gun and shoots the individual, apparently.
And this is the case that you will see made
during this press conference mistaking her
gun for her taser, which is immediately raising
questions about how could that be called an
accident.
If you are a police officer, it's your sort
of main thing to know.
Do I have a Taser in my hand or do I have
a gun?
Are these my hand handcuffs or is this a soda?
But we're going to get to that.
The man killed by police was identified by
relatives and by Minnesota Governor Tim Walts
as DONTAE, right, 20 years of age.
NBC reports that the state mobilized the National
Guard when crowds gathered in front of the
Brooklyn Center Police Department on Sunday
evening.
A curfew was ordered.
It's been chaotic.
Let's get into the clips, one of the strangest
video police press conferences that I've ever
seen.
Here's the first part where Chief Tim Gannon
says, listen, the officer announced the Taser
but drew her handgun.
That sort of seems like the officer meant
to tase Donte, right.
Not shoot Donte.
Right.
As you can hear, the officer, while struggling
with Mr. Right.
Shouts Taser, Taser several times.
That is part of the officer's training prior
to deploying a Taser, which is a less lethal
device that is done to make her partners aware,
as well as a subject that a Taser deployment
will be imminent.
During this encounter, however, the officer
drew their handgun instead of their taser
for informational purposes.
We train with our handguns on our dominant
side and our Taser on our weak side.
So if you're right handed, you carry your
firearm on your right side and you carry a
Taser on the left.
This is done purposefully and it's trained
as I watch the video and listen to the officer's
commands, is my belief that the officer had
the intention to deploy their taser, but instead
shot Mr. Right with a single bullet.
This appears to me, from what I viewed in
the officer's reaction and distress immediately
after that, this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in the tragic death of Mr. Right.
So the officer yelled a Taser and was distressed.
So therefore, it was an accident.
And that's the statement from the police chief.
Now, what the police chief calls an accident
by the law could be manslaughter.
And this has been ruled a homicide.
Remember, homicide can be murder, but it can
also be manslaughter.
Brooklyn Center Minnesota Police Chief Tim
Gannon was asked, did you authorize the use
of tear gas and rubber bullets during the
protests?
He essentially says yes.
Was it your decision to release a tear gas
and to fire bullets?
No rubber bullets at the gas station.
This is I'm a police chief in a city.
Police action is made by me.
The decision is made by me.
Does that answer your question?
Then a reporter says, you know, if the reason
for the stop was not having a license plate
or having an expired license plate, are you
aware that there's currently a multi month
delay on license plates here and the police
chief just walks out of the press conference,
significant delay.
Are you aware that there's a significant delay
in getting towns and things of this nature
from the DMV so even people who have purchased
taps are unable to give them because there's
a two to three month backlog.
Are you aware of that?
And is your staff also aware of that?
And have you made any type of recommendations
to your staff to be mindful that we're in
the middle of a pandemic and don't pull people
over potential, particularly because there
is a significant delay in getting those tapes
from the Department of Motor Vehicles?
Are you aware of that?
I am aware that police I'm aware that this
is staff aware.
Yes, there.
That was the last question.
I'm sorry.
Mr. Mayor.
Mr. Mayor, back to you.
In that video, the female officer clearly
made a fatal mistake.
So this was very abrupt, bizarre.
He just walks off and the Brooklyn City manager
appears to be unable to explain why that happened.
Mr. Mayor, when I asked that question about
the firing of the police officer, the police
chief.
Let's go.
What is that an indication of?
Is he dealing with something perhaps more
important or is there some type of silent
protest because he left immediately?
Immediately.
I can't speculate.
Mr. Mayor.
I do not know why.
Why does that bother you?
Without knowing why that he just walked out?
I do not know why the chief left.
You know, I can only speculate as to why why
he left.
You know, at the time that he did
find out what your speculation.
I don't I don't have any speculation.
I mean, it's possible that, you know, the
chief, you know, takes the position perhaps
similar to the city manager, that, you know,
there needs to be, you know, some some kind
of a process or, you know, I don't know.
I can only speculate.
And I believe from the amount of coffee I
saw him shrug, he needed to empty his bladder.
Like, how odd is all of this stuff now?
Then here is where it gets even crazier.
The police chief comes back.
Did someone tell him off screen that look
terrible, get back out there.
So he's back and then he says the officer
needs due process.
Yes, sir.
May I ask you directly, as I asked the mayor,
do you believe the officer who fired the fatal
shot and I understand there's due process.
We get that.
But ultimately, she shot and killed a 20 or
20 year old man.
The mayor has indicated she should be terminated.
What's your position on that?
My position is that officer afforded due process,
just like anybody else does.
She has the right to be heard.
She has the right to give her statement.
She has a right to tell what she felt, what
she thought, not what, not what I thought,
not what I saw, but what she thought and what
she.
And that may have an impact.
She's on administrative time.
What can you tell?
She will she will not be she will not be returning
to duty until this investigation has run its
course.
And she for all intents and purposes, I think
we can look at the video and ascertain whether
or not she'll be returning.
So everything the chief says there is correct.
Of course, the officer does get due process.
They should be on administrative leave and
they are.
That's not the issue.
The issue is more this guy's bizarre attitude,
demeanor, walking out, walking back in.
Now, I'm already getting a ton of emails from
people saying this officer is going down.
This is clear manslaughter.
They're going down for manslaughter.
Others saying they're not getting anything
here.
I'm going to give you my both non-legal expert
and cynical opinion about this case.
I believe that this officer will not be found
guilty of any criminal wrongdoing.
I think that you will either see, as far as
criminal goes, something settled, resolved
an agreement before this ever gets to trial,
or if it goes to trial, you will see an acquittal
and you will see a civil settlement for big
bucks with the family of DONTAE.
Right.
Why do I say this?
There's no question that if you mean to take
someone and you pull out a gun and you kill
them, that's manslaughter, colloquially speaking.
But the way that police shootings are handled
in the legal system with the taser warning,
they will they're already pulling the games
of, well, you know, this is someone who had
a run and he had a I think it was a warrant
for some minor drug related thing.
They're going to pull out all the games that
they normally do.
I'm not giving you my moral opinion.
I'm giving you simply my prediction.
I think that we will see no guilty verdicts
criminally for this officer and likely a big
financial settlement with the family.
It's going to be a long time.
It could be years before we ever get to that
resolution.
But that's that's my sense at this point in
time.
Tell me your thoughts